first of all y'all are the most adorable
thing to walk into the room it's so cute
and secondly do you bring all the the
shows gifts like what's that for well I
heard there was a birthday girl
oh but I do have something that's
amazing well from us oh okay give joy to
open it out she showed up it was a
rapture you sound like such a mess right
now I just signed it I have no idea you
got wait I'm gonna do oh wait what is
this oh it's over hey did you know that
I'm actually really into rocks and gems
did you know that you did No thank you
so much for having us on the show yes
Riley just went out to her frozen party
and I hear you used to love frozen -
right loved it like when the first movie
came out it was like one of the biggest
movies like I watched it every night and
then I'd cry whenever else like I love
them and they'd let it go such an
original song it's so great have you
seen frozen - yes I loved I'm 37
I don't care yes I sing it along with my
daughter and I don't care yeah yeah
you're never too old to love Disney yes
okay so what when you're a kid I was
yeah I was that little kid I grew up in
front of a TV um well they were it
usually like superhero cartoons or you
know dating myself but like Fat Albert
was yeah I'm a 70s kid that's awesome
that's a good one
so um you're being inducted into the WWE
right the holidays
[Applause]
I'm in any space where you're about to
fight me I'm just running away no I'm
actually I'm the nicest person in this
room terrifying looking if you're
getting in a fight with it it's helped
me it's weird it's not like in here it's
all gushy and it's like rainbows and
butterflies but yeah but I have that I
guess I have that look I look like that
was teach be wise all right always geez
I say this about myself as I look like I
just broke out of prison did you get
have to give Chloe any tips on like
being an action star no we talked more
about I think drama and bouncing off
each other and and just acting in
general no action tips but we worked out
in a few facials and whatnot you know
it's question wait what what's your
foots the face expression well my my
publicist has dubbed it rest in action
face because I have yeah cause like I
said I usually look intimidating but I'm
usually happy inside but I just have
rest in action face yeah can I see it
like what's yeah you want to see Chloe's
first I want to see Chloe's real bad yes
oh my god you could far scarier from a
little human that was really too good
Chloe um
what is yours like which camera are we
working with okay you're America's yeah
it all up in here yes
look at this get in there
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay okay so I can do it I can do it I'm
gonna do it right now
are you ready where's the camera where
am I looking you right now you're not
ready for this more I've got this we'll
look out a mural okay you did the drop
down I'm gonna do that too yeah now
you're tiny and weak and I'm the
opposite so the objective of this
exercise is to get past me now a good
idea might be to cause the distraction
because otherwise there'd be zero chance
of you
[Applause]
so Chloe someone told me that Dave got a
little too intense on set that you know
there might have been a swear jar oh you
know actually he was swearing swearing
earlier backstage and I have you
contributed to that jar it got to the
point where I was just like I was paying
her so much I needed credit because I
know I don't know maybe half of it maybe
half of maybe not the hundred bucks or
so it was like - it was like two dollars
a customer then that was like five bucks
yeah see I tell my kids you can curse
like mommy when you pay your bills like
mommy you can say whatever you like
yeah we were all I mean we're okay with
it cuz we knew we were all aware that
there was children on set we need to be
better about it was just something that
guess what you're in a rhythm of
speaking a certain way throughout your
life yeah it's hard to can you know
continue control but we you know we made
an effort she donated all the money yeah
I donated it to the Amazon rainforest
because you know when it's set on fire
it was like 256 dollars that's how many
people were swearing on set it is so
hard it is sad for children it's hard
but I did hear that you want to be an
animator and you spoke about that a bit
already BAM that's really cool what a
cool thank you gift and job and and and
is that something you really want to
pursue in your older yeah for sure I
love our like you know when it comes to
all that also animating just creating a
story but you know not having to make it
with real people but like when you have
an idea of what you want somebody to
look like you can bring it to life in
animation and then I like about it
that's an amazing dream animation very
cool thanks
when you were a little kid I wanted to
be alive and I grew up great
circumstances I grew up in the hood I
was surrounded by you know a lot of
violence like crime yeah I was a
definitely a product of my environment
yeah I kind of snapped out of it when I
was older when I realized it was kind of
a dead-end Road my mom helped me you
know she she sent me to live with my dad
when I was I think about 12 13 when I
was bigger than her and getting in tons
of trouble yeah so I really didn't know
I didn't honestly know what I wanted to
do with my life like for the rest of my
life I was about 30 years old and that's
when I knew that I wanted to be I wanted
to entertain people that's so cool and
so cool to say and own because a lot of
people give up on their dreams because
they think they've aged out of whatever
bracket Society tells you you're
supposed to be in and that's cool I get
30 you were like I want to do this yeah
I really my life started at 30 yeah and
I wasted my twenties I bounced in my
clubs from the time I was 17 till I was
30 Wow yeah that's what I did
right on and you're all gooshy like wish
you looked any better she's like wait
what your childhood even when I wanted
to professional wrestling because I was
such an introverted kid she just like
that's you speaking in front of
thousands of people I just yeah you
can't believe it
but my mom is actually my my biggest fan
by far that's so cool
but let's talk about my spy because I
ever tell everybody if they don't know
what the movies about what it's about
you want to tell him my spy was kind of
about you know this girl Sophie it's not
very good CIA agent and you know how he
comes across this family in them yes so
he sent out to watch this family they're
actually looking for the families a
relative of the families in this room a
couple who and because he's not a very
good CIA agent he's discovered
blackmails him
interesting character like some of the
things she would pull off like I don't
know I would say in real life she's a
you know she you know she's got the
nerve to mess with a guy like this bit
yeah
all you gotta do is push over his fish
apparent yeah but it's really about
people being misplaced and you know kind
of learning from each other and like she
helps you with things that I need help
but then I help her with things that she
needs help when we create a bond and
it's so cute the connector which is
hoping and crying in the movie yeah I
love that who would be a better spy in
real life who's the better liar I say
he's a better life I think I don't think
she can lie I don't think she's capable
I can I've told a few lies and in my
life but I just a few oh gosh I am
definitely not going to heaven I think
she would be the better spy because
she's she's smarter I think she's more
clever and she can also blend in a lot
better I'm not very discreet yeah I mean
like you know they have that cute lie a
lie detector seed cleanse in the movie
and you know yeah I'm just saying like
the trailer is just the surface of the
entire movie like there's so much more
to the film yeah you know they leave
them in those like two minutes yeah the
trailers literally just the surface of
the film there's so much more I can't
wait my kids are we're gonna love
watching it so thank you so much guys
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going